bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation une société
d'intelligence économique au dimension
européenne voire mondiale
et bien 20 ans que la france en réel
aujourd'hui elle tient au moins deux
candidats l'a dit et à visa partners je
reçois le fondateur et président d'un
visa partners bonjour matthieu creux
journalier valorisation pourquoi en 2010
vous êtes assez jeune vous choisissez de
créer une société dans l'intelligence
économique
je pense que j'avais envie d'aider mon
pays les entreprises du pays j'avais
travaillé en cabinet ministériel j'avais
noté qu'on pouvait faire beaucoup de
veille mais pas forcément agir
concrètement pour aider les grandes
entreprises à mieux comprendre les
risques qui les entoure et les gérer et
un peu presque par hasard la vie de
l'entreprise et la vie d'entrepreneur et
pas forcément fait de powerpoint on se
dit on va créer une telle aventure et
dans dix ans elle le devient on a monté
une petite entreprise de trois personnes
en 2010 et aujourd'hui on est presque
300 et 15 filiales c'est à peu près dans
plutôt une croissance externe avec un
certain nombre de rachat c'est ça moi le
choix moitié-moitié on a on a toute
notre vie surtout le au démarrage
évidemment fait que la croissance
organique on allait chercher des
nouveaux clients et ça nous a permis de
grandir et au fur et à mesure on s'est
mis à avoir une position d'acquéreurs
sur le marché on s'est dit qu'il fallait
structurer un marché français très
émietté avec énormément de petites
entreprises et on s'est rapproché de
gens qui étaient nos partenaires et nos
prestataires qui étaient nos apporteurs
d'affaires et qui progressivement nous
ont rejoints comme comme comme associé
lorsque y rentrer dans l'aventuré et
effectivement on a aujourd'hui une
vingtaine trentaine de petites sociétés
qui sont en fait issus de toutes ces
acquisitions ou deux de nos fils à
l'étranger puisque on est présent dans
cinq ou six pays dans l'ombre alors à
qui appartient le capital d'adlpartner
75% à ses managers oui
il n'y a pas de
ses managers d'aujourd'hui qui semble
patron de pays qui sont des patrons
d'activité et 25% à des investisseurs
non 2019 on a on a décidé de trouver des
fonds d'investissement pour rejoindre le
capital avec plusieurs objectifs premier
objectif c'était vraiment de trouver des
alter ego on nous apprend à grandir vous
savez la solitude de l'entrepreneur elle
est réelle on n'a pas de chef ou de
patron pour pour vous donner des
objectifs investisseurs nous en donne ne
serait ce que par sa présence
et puis on avait aussi envie de pouvoir
casser un peu l'image un peu vieillotte
la bouquerie de l'intelligence
économique où l'idée c'était d'ouvrir
nos portes de de montrer qui on est est
de faire venir des auditeurs et par
rapport à notre performance économique
ou opérationnelles de pouvoir derrière
avoir une valorisation la rendre
publique c'étaient les salaires
aujourd'hui à des centaines de millions
d'euros qui démontre bien qu'il ya un
immense marché un très grand potentiel
et une qualité d' équipe dont je suis
très fier des investisseurs qui sont pas
n'importe qui puisque deux grands
investisseurs rives croissance qui
appartient la banque populaire et
réinvestissements alors là ce on
retrouve toutes les sociétés du cac 40
les investissements c'est plus qu'un
fond la science est une société
d'investissement qui regroupe la les
investissements stratégiques d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises parmi
lesquels on retrouvera l'instant celui
de
la fondation france la caisse des dépôts
et des consignations donc indirectement
on a toutes ces entreprises par
l'intermédiaire de réalisant de capital
et est à nouveau ça nous rend fiers ça
nous aide à grandir ça exprime aussi le
souhait de ces grandes entreprises
d'investir dans des sociétés qui les
aide qui les aident à l'international
qui les aident à gérer un certain nombre
de risques auxquels sont confrontés tous
les jours justement les quatre grands
services d'un visa c'est quoi alors
cybersécurité évidemment les jeux je ne
ferai pas l'affront de vous expliquer
tous les tous les grands risques cyber
que courent les grandes entreprises qui
sont très exposés par la digitalisation
de leurs produits la gestion du risque
économique on va retrouver
l'investigation la conformité
la lutte contre la contrefaçon les
marchés illicites
les affaires publiques et la
communication stratégique troisième
briques nouveaux niveaux le le risque
d'image est un vrai risque et on a
besoin de se faire connaître pour gagner
des marchés à l'international on a
besoin d'identifier les dirigeants on a
besoin d'eux de savoir ce que raconte
une entreprise pour qu'elle puisse
raconter une histoire assez prochain
collaborateurs et les attirer et enfin
les relations internationales donc on
accompagne les grandes entreprises dans
des dans des zones où ils sont et ne
joue pas à domicile elles sont loin de
leurs bases et elles ont besoin de mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe autour d'elle
qui sont les clients n'a plus de 500
clients aujourd'hui
on travaille vraiment pour la diversité
économique on trouve autour de soi la
folle et très grandes entreprises je
pense qu'on travaille pour les trois
quarts du cac 40 français pour prendre
un exemple mais aussi des start up mais
aussi beaucoup de pays entreprises de
taille intermédiaire et des états des
états aussi une quinzaine d'états
clients dont la france dont la france
qui est le plus gros client oui je
travaille pour la gendarmerie nationale
pour
le commandement cyber pour pour la
caisse des dépôts et des consignations
on a énormément de ou alors aussi
beaucoup de collectivités compagnie en
régions des établissements publics on
accompagne des hôpitaux parce que
l'intelligence économique ce n'est pas
simplement des sociétés et c'est je
crois que c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
dire c'est pas simplement que des
sociétés qui pourrait vendre des armes
von et du laboratoire pharmaceutique ou
quoi que ce soit et d'ailleurs qui en
qui ont toute légitimité pour le faire
mais on a aussi aujourd'hui toute la
diversité des entreprises on travaille
dans mon agricoles dans le monde des
télécoms dans le monde de l'innovation
technologique et digital mais aussi pour
des hôpitaux vous allez commencer en
2010 je veux rappeler au début
aujourd'hui la situation internationale
complètement changé l'inflation la
guerre ans en ukraine la chine qui se
referme comme on travaille en
intelligence économique avec ce monde-là
serment qui bouge c'est bien pour ça que
d'ailleurs les dirigeants besoin de
repères où ils ont besoin de savoir
avant d'aller dans un pays si l'on doit
de le faire avec untel ou untel 18
conformité ils ont besoin de savoir quel
et l'honorabilité de leurs partenaires
de leurs dirigeants enfin des dirigeants
dans les quêtes des sociétés dans
lesquelles ils vont investir ça c'est
avant d'investir date de racheter une
société ils ont besoin de savoir si
telle technologie protégée ils ont
besoin de savoir si telle dirigeants
étatiques qu'ils vont rencontrer
prochainement et fiable dans ses propos
tels qu'il les a tenus dans l'histoire
sa carrière nous c'est notre métier en
fait de leur dire et d'essayer de le
décrypter ce qu'on lit pas forcément la
presse ou à l inverse ce qu'on lit dans
la presse mais qui vont maintenant dire
et donc c'est à la fois des recherches
sur sources ouvertes comme des
recherches beaucoup plus du maine on va
sur le terrain ou des recherches
financières complexes et les clients
n'ont pas tellement changé ses 15 à 19
c'est je crois important de le dire ils
sont toujours stressé de prendre des
risques mais ils ont besoin de prendre
des risques si aujourd'hui dans une
entreprise le dirigeant ne prend pas de
risques c'est la fin de l'entreprise
c'est la fin l'entrepreneuriat est donc
plutôt que de rester tétanisés
ils ont des conseils qui leur donne un
avis extérieur qui trouve pas forcément
en interne faute de compétences ou faute
parfois de franchise et d'honnêteté et
on est là pour les accompagner d'accord
comment bosse avec l'ukraine qui fermait
maintenant avec les entreprises qui
depuis quand même assez présente les
entreprises françaises là bas beaucoup
de mes confrères dans l'intelligence
économique ont une activité par mme de
sûreté il travaille sur des plans de
rapatriement sur des plans de
sécurisation d'industrie usines qui sont
sur place nous notre côté on travaille
plutôt sur les sujets des sanctions car
ils se posent énormément les dirigeants
on le voit renault qui part de russie la
société générale qui est obligé de
vendre sa filiale pareil en russie
ça c'est un vrai risque aussi qui est
financier qui est humain parce que
derrière vous avez énormément de savoir
faire qui s'en va et c'est évident que
c'est sur tous ces sujets là que nos
clients
essaient de comprendre ce qui va se
passer demain est ce que je fais encore
bien de rester dans ce pays là et en
fait quand on le regarde n'y a pas que
l'ukraine vous avez des sanctions qui
touchent des personnalités en asie en
grand criminel en amérique du sud enfin
c'est très très large et rares sont
aujourd'hui les pays lointains sur
lesquels il faut faire attention par
l'iran marni globalement de la région
middle east de l'afrique où c'est une
zone à risque mais en même temps très
tentante énormément de potentiel la
croissance aujourd'hui des grandes
entreprises n est pas en france c'est
pas en connaissant bien le 7e
arrondissement où le 8e arrondissement
que vous allez performer il faut aller
au delà des frontières mais je crois que
c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que les grandes entreprises nous
disent toujours on a besoin de
comprendre comment grandir comment
exporter comment s'implanter
l'international comment faire des
acquisitions pour trouver des pépites ce
qui sont isolées en indonésie
au japon au brésil aidez nous à les
identifier aidez nous à comprendre si ce
qu'on fait bien et je crois que c'est
instructif matthieu creux on y est il ya
une société où deux d'intelligence
économique française au niveau européen
voire mondial
entrée c'est le pari qu'ont fait je sais
pas si on y est encore on est déjà mais
quand vous comparez avec vos concurrents
anglo-saxons ou mieux ou pas on y va on
n'est pas aujourd'hui on est dans la
centaine de millions d'euros de
valorisation ont les mêmes structures
qui font entre 300 et 1000 personnes
pour les deux sociétés précitées visa
partenaires et l'a dit les géants kroll
contrôle rice etc c'est des dizaines de
milliers de collaborateurs c'est la
location aux milliards mais néanmoins si
on prend les trajectoires de ces
dernières années on va beaucoup plus
vite qu'eux mais beaucoup plus souple ma
french touch veut dire quelque chose
internationale nous on est présent aux
états unis ont fait plus de 10 millions
de dollars de chiffre d'affaires on est
présent l'angleterre à bruxelles mais
présent à berlin
millions de chiffre d'affaires 60
millions chiffre d'affaires cette année
l'année en sachant qu'on est moins d'un
million d'euros en 2016 oui donc vous
voyez la trajectoire ont mené et non la
french touch fonctionne en tout cas là
la touche européenne et nous notre pari
consiste à essayer de créer un champion
européen si possible à pavillon
tricolore je pense qu'on va y arriver on
a peut-être fait le plus dur c'est à
dire en gros le décollage émerger et
maintenant il nous reste beaucoup de
travail à penser à un mariage avec un
acteur je sais pas allemand italien et
espagnol
passicos à jour est-ce que ça passera
pas sa part ça on y pense tous les jours
à la fois je dis toujours à mes équipes
il faut fidéliser nos clients il faut en
trouver de nouveaux et il faut se
rapprocher de ceux qui en ont et qui
nous permettront de diversifier nos
offres de renforcer notre fonds de
commerce et oui je pense que dernière
question en europe continentale à visa
partner c'est le géant ou pas je pense
qu'on est dans le top 5 sans difficulté
merci beaucoup mathieu croyons vos
réponses l'entretien de l'intelligence
et communité terminée mais évidemment
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
france 24 points comme sur nos réseaux
sociaux et sur nos podcasts au revoir
[Musique]